all right 320. this is your distance
dude if you're locked and loaded
you got a good bounce off the tree
hey it's trevor siegrist we are in my
hometown and we're going to be hitting
some local businesses with my wells
fargo active cash visa card
we are so proud
just a little something off the top baby
that's what you think
oh it's unbelievable yeah that's the
best place
service
we're gonna be right here
when i turned pro i didn't have time and
carlos very far away from uh from
newport beach to uh
cut my hair so it was getting pretty
long so i had to get a little trim and
it didn't go great so all the guys were
making fun of me i'm very superstitious
about where i get my hair cut didn't i
say that yeah that's right i said that
thing's been going good since i've been
getting my hair cut here so
i don't always get this type of special
treatment
okay handsome wonderful
thank you
i can see you again carla
thank you carla my pleasure don't wait
so long
now that i got my hair cut i'm gonna pop
over next door and see my mom in her
store
hey mom what do we think of the haircut
i love it what do you think looks good
not bad we're fluffy in the back yeah
little fluffy
i think i'm gonna need a baby gift for
my uh my old teammate my mom has had
this store for 14 years after school
come here and kind of hang out
never do any homework or anything
this is the baby area right here yeah
baby section his first year in the pros
was so exciting for all of us we had a
lot of late nights here in new york
trying to stay up stay up 10 p.m games
but we did it and just to be along for
the ride is so much fun
so we're gonna do this
and how's that
i feel good about the baby gift we got
my stuffed bunny mommy and my brother
are gonna go up to the country club and
hit a couple balls maybe play a couple
holes check out the pro shop i'll show
them how it's done
[Music]
how are you
just gonna do a little shopping if
that's okay
you need a shirt what are you thinking
what's your favorite color i'm liking
the red one you like the red this one's
nice besides that's a large though it
might be too big
medium it's our little guy
we might need one of these though a
range finder see how far out you are
how much further my ball is than yours
thank you
awesome thank you so much you've been
practicing you hear those sounds at
night that's me chipping in the backyard
i knew that's what that was i'd say i
probably swing a little bit harder out
here on the golf course than i do on the
ice when i'm golfing it's more just
brute power and see how far i can hit it
all right it's your box dude
yeah i'll give you the line griff hey
all right 320. this is your distance
dude you're locked and loaded
[Music]
you got a good bounce off the tree good
thing you guys moved you know the wind
was playing
strong crowd's growing the wind was
playing strong oh yeah
i don't have to do much to beat that
she'll play
just past yours like that just barely
past yours a lot of trees from here in
18 buddy hey
i didn't even see where yours went i had
a great day shopping and hanging out in
bedford and i love that i earned
unlimited two percent cash rewards on my
purchases with my wells fargo active
cash card i mean honestly i don't even
know if we'll be able to find your ball
dude